[Music]
when Stefani and Blake Shelton live it
up at a pals wedding the pair looked
adorable Saturday night attending the
romantic affair when captured this cute
moment of Blake who was in the wedding
party making his grand entrance they
spent time with the bride and groom
Blake posed for pics with the flower
girls and not surprisingly when got
summoned to the dance floor like Gwen
started dating in late 2015 they've
never been shy about how much they love
each other but fans want to know if
marriage is on their minds think about
it I don't know I think it's anytime
soon or anything but you know the more
time that goes by I guess the closer
you'd be getting to that well then all
right we'll just think about it there's
no there's no rush but I do I think
about it all the time back in March a
source told e.t Blake and Gwen are
closer than ever but not rushing to the
altar they said quote they're on cloud
nine for each other they know they have
found their true soulmate
[Music]
[Applause]